all right I'm trying I'm trying a real
pro move here I'm sure it's gonna work
just women oh yeah just didn't pop up so
I was like Bach seems weird did you blow
all this no I did not I don't believe in
blowing before a man he prays be all
right where is he he her obviously hard
who's laughing no just keep going down
that hallway don't don't come back here
I'm fine shut up I'm back here don't
know well I'm gone now obviously I know
he's lying yeah I'm actually a huge
thing you you should probably see me
sitting out there yeah this vending
machine is not hurting me when I shoot
it all right I alright give you some pin
I'll give you some hints actually
working you guys have gone on some
stairs since you saw me and I am in a
room that you have already looked in I'm
not does is create a errors Jesus in the
room where you guys got the RPG rates I
can't believe you got hoes so quick Jack
though yeah
good yours is terrible not good you're
against my - somebody how can you win
okay where are you Bob
okay Jack or what yeah I did
this door is open what are you upstairs
sir where are you yeah yeah yeah in the
room where you were right downstairs in
the library and I don't see anything
super out of the ordinary you already
seem to be hidden in this library yeah
it's like a tiny tin can oh yeah who
knows tiny tin can is that your next
adorable character mark don't you dare
make fun of tiny bugs him yeah shoot
that fire chili that's it the rounds
over all right you won good job
probably lots of Todd's is creating
errors geez have you looked under the
ovens because I'm pretty sure you can go
underneath I can't get out of either so
[Music]
yeah what huh
nobody's acted uses have no idea huh
nothing what these sausages weren't here
before through there I didn't do
anything it's over it's over it's not
over to the counter girl singsong I'm
boned yeah you're in trouble watch why'd
you help me hide you should have been
running away in oh you're probably fine
plants over I knocked one of them over
one of them was not okay just ignore the
plants and admire my genius yeah these
guys here doors now they're there uh I
think they're in the club no no no no no
stairs uh I can't get out I don't trust
you new building yeah they're in the
club downstairs I think he's coming
upstairs now though cuz I sort of gave
away our position I'm angry and you will
say I gave away our position we are
pretty close together uh-huh yeah but I
can't even see you anymore
I can see anybody I'm just very slippery
and gross he's a fish fish fish
I'm also tall how's that very Tony are
you an adult toy he's a tough oh yeah
you could say that are you are well oh I
don't know I don't know how how you
determine whether I'm well used or not
down generation to generation between
dildo users of my great-grandmother used
to be on her great great
I'm downstairs in the bar first went oh
my god yeah you passed me mark you said
you weren't there and then you were liar
yeah I was in Bashan somewhere in here
oh you've only got five seconds you
better pick oh I was the stripper pole
oh my
[Music]
Oh